I've seen about the original Seven
because everyone says that's good and I
I [__] on the graphics a lot so I was
kind of like maybe I should the [__]
egg beater yeah no they look like Roblox
characters or Worse
um oh that I don't know right everyone
says tan everyone's just like yeah Pete
keeps saying six yeah
because every every single [__] uh
old person magazine is like six is the
best for real Gamers because it's it is
it's the Pinnacle the Final Fantasy
design it is but it's on the SNES and
I'm like dude it's come on my twitch
Chad they're like 12. oh okay yeah okay
okay
it was uh yeah I liked it the story was
okay though I think so it was okay yeah
because it felt like I don't know if
other jrpgs do this it was like in the
start it's like hey we got the gang the
gang's great and like halfway through
the game like all right um only the main
characters really matter now so only the
main two everyone else is kind of like
on the side yeah 10 10 I feel definitely
has a better story
um like the sister the combat system and
like the the the
how scaling system is all like this
figure system is like actually intuitive
and yeah yeah it looks makes it look
like [__] oh man I kind of yeah I'm
thinking about that I was like damn I've
been playing fortnite lately that's been
kind of fun fortnite's coming
fortnite's kind of good you know what
I'm telling you fortnite's good again
when you said your audience for 12 I
thought you were joking yeah you were
joking as well I got roped into playing
a few games of fortnite I was like
oh my mouse okay and I was like all
right fine I'll play one game and I was
like I'm not playing football it's for
little babies I sort of playing I was
like oh [__] it's kind of fun though I
am a little baby
oh [__]
oh [__] oh [__] it is kind of fun uh so
I'm on the the two sides of the game of
spectrum at the moment I'm gonna
dabbling my feet in all of it yeah yeah
um this is fun I've been really enjoying
gaming lately actually I kind of fell
out of it for a little while I've been
getting back into it and I've been
really into it
well I was only really playing TFT I hit
Master by the way nobody asked
um the season ended but I hit Master
which is crazy because I never hit
Master before that's like the top not
the top top because it's still too but
it's pretty crazy for League it's pretty
hard to do yeah um so I was happy I
believe you Joey's sick was just the
most neutral I'm happy for you but I
have no idea what you're talking about
it's like virginity
I'm not gonna read that but I'm happy
I'm sorry for you
I was just like casually playing that
and I was like cool that's cool that I
managed to do something while casually
doing it like yeah like committing not
like I played way more on the tour so I
was like oh man I strongly had Diamond
Back Then I was ready yeah yeah I mean I
I've uh I guess I've fallen in love with
gaming as well or something you know I
don't know
for the first time yeah I've been
playing uh Jedi Survivor recently oh
[__] I didn't expect you to play that
yeah I mean here's the thing like I said
I really want to get like I said this on
the previous podcast where I really
[__] love soulsborne games I just
don't like the setting and uh you know I
don't like the Dark Fantasy setting uh
so despite how good they are it takes me
a lot to get invested into it because
you know it it takes a really good game
to get me invested into it uh Jedi
survivors is just the setting that I
[__] love which is not exactly Star
Wars but futuristic sci-fi with the same
kind like enough of the same kind of
gameplay that you'd expect not as good
as Elden ring which is why I think I'm
warming up to like finally starting
Eldon ring maybe on stream because I've
really really enjoyed Jedi Survivor
um I've been enjoying that I've been
enjoying the exploration but one thing
like the the one I wouldn't say downside
okay
as a gamer do you care about Cosmetics
no we're in what way okay so Jedi
survivors kind of similar to like
something like you know Elden ring or
something where you explore the world
there are bosses and sometimes there are
a lot of chests and uh what I've
realized is that most of the chests they
they dropped like lightsaber parts or
blaster parts or clothing and jrpg mind
originally I thought oh great start
upgrades let me just equip everything
nope it's all completely cosmetic and
I'm like who cares about this yeah I'm
sure there are people who do
I'm the reason why micro transactions
exist because I I only care about
Cosmetics when it's interacting with
other players because then it's like
it's important to like it's like like
would I dress nicely if I never left my
house no is the answer right yeah
because no one's seeing it right it's
like that in video games too I'm like I
want to make sure everyone sees my
little funny Fortnight but you're out of
the house
I say that as if I didn't
listen I I found more skin than I stuck
to it yeah so it's like that yeah I mean
I if you if I don't give a [__] about
single player I I want whatever stats
the highest yeah yeah give me start up
Grace yeah which is why like I never
understood like you know I I'm that kind
of guy who has never understood the
types of people who when they start a
new game and they see the character
creations and they get [__] excited
like oh my God I get to create my
character they spend like three hours
making their characters and I'm like
those are people who have drawn their
OCS before
the same type of people yeah it's like
half the time that
creating is in like full armor or some
[__] that you're never going to see in
your life you know I see a sliver of the
customers
pick the dick length it didn't matter I
didn't even get to see it if I I wish
there was like a scene that at least
utilized it yeah they were like oh you
got it I want to see a cutscene where my
OC and his micro [__] is just sticking
out yeah like cyberpunk made the least
sense to me because that's the first
person [__] game you don't ever see
your character because like 90 of the
time because it's like I do like it in
cutscenes though and your characters
like looks goofy as [__] oh that's why I
like it in GTA yeah
there's some really serious scene just
your goofy ass is just standing there
that'll do that that's the one time yeah
yeah you got like a naked man in like a
cutscene I love that I love that so much
that cracks me up yeah but then when it
cuts in the characters wearing like the
pre you know the cutscenes already been
dying like [__] this yeah
yeah just like for me just give me the
default character to the just give me
like the default everything I don't
really care I hate it when you get that
kind of stuff in chess because then you
just turn your brain off to like chess
or whatever you're like it's all going
to be [__] yeah yeah yeah exactly which
is which is why I've enjoyed it but I've
kind of like now that I'm like 20 hours
in or something I'm like I don't want to
explore anymore because 90 of the [__] I
find is just cosmetic stuff that doesn't
matter and I know there is like some
upgrades in the world but I'm like this
just like around this corner could just
be another chest I don't know like is it
actually worth it yeah yeah yeah yeah
yeah
that sucks I've also been playing
balloons tower defense again I saw I
actually I was I was I was uh on my
computer
balloons tower defense and I was like
it's kind of streaming and he's I said
and he there was no C doc stream and I'm
like this [__] is just playing
blues for fun I had like 40 minutes and
I was like I watched this YouTube video
because I've been in that phase again
where I gotta listen to YouTube videos
to sleep and I found this it was like a
three hour video about balloons tower
defense I had like eight million views
and I was like oh I know this is gonna
be a banger and uh that's when I yeah
that's how I know when essays are good
when you just see like a stupid view
count with a weirdly specific topic yeah
yeah yeah this is good [__] yeah and I
watched it and I was like ah I kind of
want to get back into Bloons and I
started playing it and I was like ah
it's kind of good this kid is good they
have it is correct it's a solid game
yeah for sure because they just keep up
dating it they had short stuff it's bad
because I'm playing it and and I I feels
like a five minute game and I and I look
at the timer I'm like dude I've been
playing this for 40 minutes and I it's
I've badly done anything I'm just
watching the balloons pop it's like it
does feel like I'm developing ADHD while
I'm doing it like I feel like I'm I'm
like this feels like a weird hack on my
brain to like magically lose time
um so I've been doing I've been trying
to get it on second monitor but it keeps
loading on my main monitor see I can't I
can't laugh at that because I've also
recently just casually gotten back and
playing Minesweeper again
that's very active that's not a that's
not like Bloons don't just press play
what [__] comes in
says I just casually go back into mines
well because like ages ago when I was
still streaming I I did that you know
offhand stream where I was like I'm
gonna learn how to play mine sweeping
and I planned on playing it for like
five hours I beat expert once during
that entire history so I was but then I
was like
I could get a better time and so last
couple of days I've just been whenever I
have time I just put some music on like
put something on the record player and I
just [__]
[__] I don't want to ever hear it from
you if you're busy now [__] I don't want
to ever hear their excuse that you're
busy you know I just realized uh so it's
been it's been two weeks since the last
trash days recording since I had like a
week holiday is this the type of [__] we
get up to when we have no trash Chase
recordings in a week
I have made sure that I've been busy but
occasionally you have like an hour you
know I have to I have to I have to and
then normally I would play TFT but I
stopped because I reached mastered I'm
like I was waiting for a business call
it was two hours down I was like what am
I gonna do for two hours
[__]
[Music]
I was doing like 30 minutes of balloons
okay
yeah I don't know I I feel like they're
like I feel like those kinds of game is
just like the equivalent of watching
Tick Tock with Subway Surfer at the
bottom you know it's just a way just to
keep your mind engaged yeah uh it is
I was like my brain could just like rot
on the couch doing nothing or it could
stay active and Young by playing
Minesweeper for two yeah because I never
really got like I never really got how
the kind of Rise of idol games came out
like was like Cookie Clicker or whatever
that game was like I never I never like
to me I never understood how that became
a genre well I mean I think that like
it's like people are just want to do
something else then quickly you just
kind of you have to actively do it and
stop then you can just kind of watch it
yeah and it's you know it's like how you
maybe you would you know you'd watch
your TV and talk to your friend back in
the day I feel like it's just evolutions
of that right
is it is it it's just the brain getting
all scattered it is I I feel like it's
just a like something hacking in our
brain because I thought it was like dumb
until uh like honkai Star rail released
this uh uh event recently where it's
like a museum management thing it's not
Museum management all you do is you
click you click buttons and then you see
numbers go up and then you have to get
it so every every number is S rank and
then I've realized that I wasted like
two and a half hours so that's just the
yuck as a side quest
that's literally this like the stock
broker game in Yonkers yeah yeah
and I'm like whatever I'm like why am I
doing this right now and why can I not
stop why why can I not stop something is
going wrong with my brain right now I I
just I just but that was the best part
of some of the youngsters those like
[__] like business management side
quests where you just click some [__]
and you watch it grow got it yeah all
I'm doing is watching some numbers get
bigger and the more numbers get bigger
the more resources you have to make the
bigger numbers get even bigger and then
and then it's like the gameplay Loop of
big numbers equal bigger number and more
big resources equal bigger number and
then it's just and and then it doesn't
end I'm like what why why am I doing
this I don't know why I'm doing this but
I can't stop because I need to see
bigger numbers internally satisfying
that's a YouTube mentality
we do that with our sub count as always
keep going that is just YouTube in a
nutshell bro this is what trash taste
gets up to when uh when we don't have a
tragedies recording apparently